oh i love this skirt i've worn this i
think it's so
cool love a good pocket that's for sure
this is my favorite to wear on the set i
think i've even had it worn in shows
but it's just it is
heaven heaven heaven
closet is such a happy place
one of the things we decided to do with
this show
and this closet that we were just
starting to build at the beginning of
the show
was this idea of shop the look
[Music]
lee is able to pull from all these
extraordinary designers
and he has such a wide range of love of
designers
we thought what if we could show people
honor the designers we're wearing and
the clothes we're wearing
that range from more expensive to
you know all different price ranges that
we could get a shop to look
that's like really attainable really
close to it
and include people in the process of
if you wanted to get an outfit like this
here's a way to do that
um as well as acknowledge all the
amazing
you know designers we work with on the
show
[Music]
this one i wore really early on in the
show
it's in like a clip where i'm always
dancing
like in this shirt is in every show
the argyle socks were my idea actually
me he got me this big arrangement
and then he also got me like tinier and
different sized prints with them
but i thought when we don't want to wear
tall
boots we could wear really cool shoes
with those kind of socks as a stocking
almost
[Music]
of course there's always the signature
flower coming in
you know really layered looks
like the classic old drop lauren
type of combination it's really fun
to build this closet and then get to
share it with everyone
as in hey is this speaking to you here's
a way
you could shop it and
we save everything so we don't keep
rebuying we keep bringing in new pieces
and adding
but it's great to keep reusing too so
that is us in the closet
you can never ever ever
go wrong with a trench
so
i always have to leave my clothes here
but i gotta keep working so i get to
wear this outfit out of the studio
so throw on a trench
and never fail
done